dealing with the effects of the manchet
and the blame being on her if she acts
differently so on that same topic if you
act differently if your wife has had
another man's dick in her mouth
naturally you would there's no h there's
no man right here it's completely
different
no
let me explain to you why my brother
first of all yeah more than likely
you're the person going down on one knee
so you have decided that a that's my
wife right yeah she could wait until
kingdom come for you to go down on the
knee and you don't have to go down on me
right yeah so that means you've
committed to her yeah yeah right and
she's accepted your commitment yeah yeah
knowing who you are
and she knows what a man is like already
she knows you're a predisposition yeah
correct or no yeah right so when you act
out on that predisposition that she
already knows of she is already
calculating in her head the way out of
it
because she's already hypergamous so i'm
going for a rich man knowing that he's
going to cheat
knowing that i'm going to take him for
half a stop no no no okay hold on
hold on yeah i know that i'm going to
i'm going to go with a man that's highly
likely going to cheat correct or no not
necessarily ask these girls and they'll
tell you highly likely a man is going to
cheat or a man is thinking about
cheating so it's hard you're saying when
the woman is saying yes i do or yes i i
do want to marry she's already
considering it that's one mighty woman
wait i i agree with him and this and the
point that a woman will know the type of
value man she's getting with has the
ability
to exercise his options i don't know
what she hold on everybody knows that
so
yeah she's weighed up a risk
as to whether
this is possible now here's my here's my
other guy if not if i'm getting married
to rihanna i'm weighing up my wrist are
you going to marry a hoe of course i'm
not going to marry you right so but
she's going to marry a hodo
yeah right she's not basically hold on
hold on look think of that understanding
you're not going to marry a whole yeah
she would marry a whole and that's the
difference
guys man okay let's say that's that's
the case but you can't eliminate human
emotion and human reasoning of course
you can't say because you knew he's a
man and he's not naturally monogamous
it's you should have known that there
was a high chance of this is ridiculous
like
listen guys you have a son and you have
a daughter
the the in the exact same situation the
guy the daughter's husband cheats the
son's wife cheats it doesn't matter
who's a male or who knew what you're
both feeling for you're feeling for them
equally regardless of the whether one's
a male ones or feet like you're not
giving them i'm giving them different
advice though yeah of course but i'm
saying you're removing the human
reaction just a natural response but
we're not taught like
it's just why are you bringing the
emotion into it no because like because
we're talking
no because the whole thing like it's
just like i feel like i'm a girl like
why are you bringing this into it
obviously obviously they're gonna have
an emotional reaction we know
you guys are overlooking the emotional
reaction and saying it's the woman the
woman is to blame not breaking up the
mouth yes i'm saying i'm saying i'm
saying women leave seventy to eighty
percent of the time ninety percent of
their college educated and i'm saying
women put their feelings before their
own kids
you knew you married dude you knew he
might cheat on you then he cheats on you
and then boo hoo poor me i need to break
up the home and put put my feelings
before my kids you know who you marry i
agree but what equally what i'm saying
is if that happens to a man the man
would leave the marriage equally whether
i knew she was going to whether i didn't
know all those things are just do you
think men and women are the same
no okay so you see you understand why
they're different you're fifty percent
there so
we just lost your job would you leave
her no right but many women would leave
their men because they lost their job a
hundred percent correct because the
women are different
what would keep them in a relationship
is different to what will keep us in a
relationship
yes yes you're a cheerleader man ish you
are the biggest cheerleader
but i'm a lion though
wait if only he had a camera okay
someone donate the whole money
no i hate i hear what you're saying i i
don't know about that so you change your
mind then let me ask you change my mind
no yes it changes by the way you guys
guess one at a time changed my mind
about what i'm saying to you yeah
if i'm going to her she already knows
i'm promiscuous yeah
she's already saying listen if he's
promiscuous he better be the best man
that i could get
yeah the best promiscuous man that i
could get because i'm already dealing
with the consequences whether or not
i'll go with a broke guy he's going to
achieve if i've got a rich guy's going
to as well go with a rich guy the rich
guy yeah
yeah yeah so yeah i'm already taken out
of the relationship what i want to and
telling her what i'm willing to accept
there's certain things in the
relationship that men are willing to
accept that a woman would never accept
in a relationship so you think it's
perfectly fine
for me to get married
all right go and cheat
come back and say do no no i think it's
perfectly fine for you to have two wives
if you want to have more than one wife
okay but
what do you mean okay what like what
first of all because that's the separate
topic because marriage to me is that's
polygamy sorry yeah i just want to say
that i've been dating all wrong like
i've just realized
obviously that tends to happen with red
paw yeah your eyes open what is red pill
no i'm just saying from the advice i'm
getting from you guys you like you and
the cheerleader yeah and this is
exciting
love doesn't exist and we've just got to
deal with what we get and you know i
think no no it's like yeah
life is about trade-offs if you want a
guy in the top 10 20 he might cheat
and if he does don't be surprised would
you would you agree that you go for a
guy
would you agree that you go for a go at
the top level knowing that there is a
higher chance it will cheat because he's
pre-selected other people are going to
wonder if he's at the top level you're
interested in him the likelihood is
other women are going to be i mean look
at it do you agree that women love other
people's men
yeah so marry an average guy that no
other girl look looks at yeah then you
won't have that problem okay yeah i'll
have a little so then you'll be bored
and you won't stay with him you'll
likely cheat so you know
like paul said it's a trade-off like
every area okay so i'm either going for
the top 20
and they're gonna cheat on me like i'm
going for the other 80
and i'm gonna cheat it's a no-win
situation
statistics
one at a time let them go statistics
what do we see with what
if if 20 percent of the women go for 100
of their men okay 100 percent of when we
go for 20. so sorry yeah yeah so what's
this what's this
what's the statistic and cheating that
the man will cheat
if he is in the top 20. oh okay it's um
so basically it's pretty equal when it
comes to cheating it's about one out of
four admit to cheating when asked right
and we can all probably attest that it
might be a little higher because people
don't always admit to it but then if you
get a guy that makes over two hundred
fifty thousand dollars per year it ups
to fifty percent so fifty percent of men
that make over two hundred fifty
thousand dollars per year it doesn't
mean all my dad didn't cheat yeah it
doesn't mean yeah and so that's what we
know of some yeah that's true that's
true um
is there a statistic
is there is there a statistic on
women who go for
average guys
or below the high level guys is there a
statistic on how many times these women
cheat
no i don't know actually because from my
personal experience
i can count on one hand right now how
many people i know women i know are
cheating on their husbands right this
very second and they have average men
and if they were with a top-tier man
they also equally understand that's just
ones i know right now i'm talking i've
never talked about in the past right
but they also admit that if they were a
top level guy they would accept him
jillian yeah i mean i think those girls
couldn't get the guys that they wanted
so they settled so they were a little
bit older yeah so they settled so they
couldn't get kids and then they cheat
with the guy they actually wanted and
sometimes they
i've seen some
numbers and i'm not sure how accurate
this is but up to like 20 25 percent of
guys are raising a kid that's not theirs
wow so can i ask you guys yeah yeah
ladies yeah if your best friend was
cheating on her partner would you tell
her partner no exactly thank you see
what's gonna say you
that's not my business that's not
that's not i don't i don't think i'm
declaring anyone's cheating i am sorry
why would you go out of your way until i
like that no i've done it
do you know what i found
i find um
you'll be the bad guy so if you if you
found out her her man was cheating on
her would you tell her
next to me would you tell your friend if
you found out her man
right so do you understand the same
thing with guys right but that's that's
because that's because you're friends
with one yeah yeah yeah
my point to that is this yeah
we already know what it's like because
we accept what it's like they don't
accept what it's like bro so you're
saying yeah but it's like that for guys
yeah i know because we accept it for
guys but they don't accept it for women
so i'm saying you don't you don't want
your man to cheat but you're not gonna
tell
um your your
your best friend's partner if your
friend's cheating on her and you're not
going to and you're going to tell you're
going to tell her if her man's cheating
okay would you honestly round with you
turn it around would you tell your best
friend that his missus was cheating yeah
of course
your best friend's misses that he was
cheating depends you wouldn't oh give me
a break about it it doesn't depends
because i have and i haven't before
oh you've actually got your best friend
you would tell his missus he's cheating
i haven't i have before yes why are you
telling her because it's acceptable
yeah if it's so honestly i'm with you
i've been on both sides at like
different points yeah depends how good
the friendship is
it's just what you said you said you
said best friend so that's that yeah
yeah yeah it still depends
yeah depends how i see how the girl is
if the girl is the sweet one yeah she's
a loyal one she's a loyal one yeah she's
a decent girl yeah you come from a
decent family and you're doing all of
that matting i'm like bro you can't do
that no naturally you would talk to your
mom
what's natural to cheat chi-chi for men
to cheat it's it's it's but this is what
i was saying earlier is that
if it is natural to cheat but if you can
and if you're dating the top
20
and you marry them and you have kids
with them then i think it's also down to
you as a woman to be
a woman that they want to be loyal to so
you are having sex with them you're not
holding it as no
if he cheated on you would you would you
leave him
that now have you got kids i haven't got
kids no so without the kids you would
leave yeah but after the kid you would
stay with him
yeah
um
yes i would
because i'll be putting the kids first
but if it was like a but if you if she
cheats speaking to the mic please so if
she cheats would you leave
i wouldn't stay with any woman who
cheated on me
and i never have i love this i love this
and it depends on what time of my life
you're assuming that men and women are
the same we aren't the same our
biologists
i'm not saying we're the same but i'm
saying loyalty are like
can we not have the same loyalty so
obviously as many of you know i was just
banned on tick tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible